[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
les campagnes électorales c'est sérieux
alors je sais bien qu'il ya plein de
gens qui pensent que les campagnes
électorales ces moments on peut raconter
n'importe quoi on peut se faire plaisir
et vas-y que je te promets ça
beaucoup de nos concitoyens pensent que
les campagnes électorales c'est quand
même le concours de la plus grosse
démagogie tue favorable à toutes les
personnes de qualité qui voudraient nous
rejoindre les symptômes bien du talent
alors que l'ukraine pourrait rejoindre
l'otan moscou se sent menacé le kremlin
a déployé 120 mille soldats à la
frontière ukrainienne un sujet au coeur
des discussions hier soir au kremlin où
le président français a été reçu en
allant voir poutine en se saisissant du
sujet en exprimant une forme de fermeté
et une envie d'avancer il se place dans
une situation où les russes peuvent lui
faire mal sur le plan électoral la
longueur de la table entre vladimir
poutine et emmanuel macron objet de
détournement infinie sur les réseaux
sociaux ça rigole pas les gestes
barrière en russie et l'ukraine est
membre de l'otan et récupère la crimée
par voie militaire
l'été les européens seront entraînés
dans un conflit avec la russie vous
serez entraînés dans un conflit vous
n'aurez même pas le temps de réagir ces
quatre mètres qui séparent et hier les
chefs d'état ont dû compliquer encore un
peu plus les négociations sur le crème
justement que la situation se stabilise
et que nous puissions réengagé
par des mécanismes de garantie nouveau
une désescalade pirates est-ce que vous
ne vous êtes pas réveillé un peu tard
sur ces questions de sécurité j'en veux
pour preuve les chiffres qui viennent de
votre propre ministère et hausse de la
violence des atteintes aux personnes
homicide en hausse coups et blessures
volontaires en très nette hausse est en
train de perdre votre sang-froid à la
macro ni
vraiment vous êtes en train de perdre
votre sang-froid c'était qu'on vous pose
des questions vous sentez offensé ça se
passe à l'assemblée nationale se passe
sur les plateaux de télé ça se passe
partout jallet votre logo je pensais
qu'on était sur ses news mais en fait on
est bien sur bfm joie par rapport à une
dit pas non plus et ce soit à jamais
parce que vous ne dites pas mais jamais
l'apa l'allocation blessés par les
balles à la main au père me
représentation elle est très rapide et
un peu populiste monsieur da manha a
perdu ses nerfs et a tenu des propos
agressifs alors contrevient aux
journalistes qui ne fait pourtant que
son travail
calmez vous madame ça va bien se passer
aujourd'hui une baisse de 30% ça va bien
se passer il y avait bien se passer
je vous demande pardon comme ça c'est
madame vous allez voir mais il ya 30 %
et à 30% de baisse sur les bien moi j'en
ai marre des discours populistes toute
la journée moi je pensais qu'on était à
l'assemblée nationale j'avais pas
compris qu'on était dans la rédaction de
télé loisirs et qu'on était en train de
commenter les émissions de télévision
j'ai entendu à gérald darmanin avec deux
intervieweurs homme employé cette même
expression choix c'est une expression
avec moi aussi avec vous c'était le
district
souvent c'est une expression qu'il se
soumet est extraordinairement cocasse
d'entendre des leçons de calme des
leçons de cannes de vous qui êtes en
train de hurler
vous êtes 200 en train de hurler contre
une jeune femme qui fait de vous narrer
la fin d'une angoisse pour ce petit
garçon qui depuis plusieurs heures était
bloqué sur ce télésiège manger derrière
des barreaux en tenue de prisonnier
c'est ce qu'ils proposent ce restaurant
de téhéran lancé pas aussi saugrenue que
ça en a l'air parce qu'en payant leurs
additions les clients aide à la
libération de vrais prisonniers
condamnés pour dettes impayées
quarante-quatre personnes ont pu être
secourues grâce à cette méthode c'est la
rupture d'une pièce mécanique qui est à
l'origine de cet art est survenu hier
après midi dans cette station du cambre
d'aze dans les pyrénées-orientales
il y à 11000 iraniens qui sont détenus
pour ne pas avoir honoré leur dette